foreign
is kicking us off this hour in New York
City Adam welcome to the show
hello George hello Ken good afternoon
thank you very much for taking the call
and happy New Year happy New Year thank
you what's going on
so I have uh speaking of nuance right
somewhat of a nuanced question that I
also think would present kind of a
deeper dive into finances and other
items but one thing that and just to
give background to the question right
I'm a younger person 30 years old have a
decent amount of savings set up and I've
been with my partner my girlfriend for
about almost three years now when you
break down in just in terms of
percentages and savings you know the Big
Goal that I have for myself is buying a
home some would have left that Arena
over the last 18 months or so due to the
crazy things you've seen in the
tri-state area more specifically New
Jersey but I have about if you could
pool our assets right maybe about 90 to
95 of what to go into and you know she's
a child of divorce people in my family
are no stranger to divorce and one thing
I'm thinking about doing is trying to
acquire a house as a premarital asset in
a way of kind of protecting myself not
knowing what the future would hold I
don't know if that's the right way to be
thinking about it but working in finance
maybe I'm Jaded by seeing this over time
and time again so maybe that's not the
best mindset to have but I can't help it
I think that could be a benefit to me in
a Smart Financial move so how is that
going to get your opinion on that before
we weigh in on the opinion and and
George leading on this one I I'm just
curious
why do you think that's a good move and
it's funny that you refer to it as a
premarital asset it's very very stuffy
very very uh you know like what do you
think it was romantic Ken no not at all
what is it what do you think it's going
to do for you
well so I've seen before where if in the
event that me and my girlfriend take the
next step and it doesn't work out within
whether that's
six months two years five years ten
years over timeline that may be hold on
a second hold on hold on hold on hold on
and I'm just trying to get context
if you take the next step does that mean
get married
correct and it doesn't work out so we're
already we're already uh planning for
the worst
uh it's something that I've done for
most of my life that I have a hard time
not doing
yeah is having the worst in your mind
and trying to plan so keep going so if
the worst happens why is having this
premarital asset known as a house why is
that protecting you
my understanding is that if
right worst case scenario would be we
get divorced
um I lose the house and now I kind of
have to restart over and my
understanding is it was a pre-marital
asset and then we decided to sell the
home we would have equal access to the
proceeds where I wouldn't essentially be
kicked out of my own house or something
like that all right George that's what I
needed to know got it now we see where
he's coming from
well you're what you're saying is and
correct me if I'm wrong you want to buy
this house your name is on the the deed
your name is on the mortgage and her
name is not a part of this at all let's
say you guys get married you would still
it would remain that way
correct
you're asking for a roommate at that
point why would she not want some skin
in the game too and say hey what's
what's mine is now ours this is we
that's a good thing so when you look at
the dating well this is my thing I had
before we were married and so I'm going
to keep it in my name to play it safe
what do you think that does to her
emotionally and mentally
yeah it's a very fair point and I hold
no ill will towards her whatsoever and
would obviously want to welcome you
didn't answer the question in my life
you did not answer the question you're a
very thoughtful young man I mean like
really thoughtful but if you're on the
answer put yourself in her shoes how do
you think she's gonna feel
terrible
all right that's just not how I want to
start the marriage Now understand the
heart of it you're scared because you've
seen this play out in your family and
you've seen people with you've seen the
YouTube comments on any video about
marriage where they're saying don't get
married it's she's just trying to take
you for all your words you're going to
take you to the cleaners they all sound
like that to me for some reason in the
comment section
and it's just a real kind of gross
Outlook towards marriage there's a lot
of negativity a lot of cynicism and I
think the best thing you can do if you
really want to go this route you can do
a prenup if there's inordinate levels of
wealth let's say you're coming in you've
got a million dollar debt worth and
she's not working or she makes a smaller
salary you could pursue a prenup as a
way to protect yourselves
but doing the kind of shady I did this
before we were married so it's mine
that's going to create a ruffle and so I
would talk about it first of all
communicate as a couple and decide
together what we're going to do if
you're even going to go that route
okay I see what you mean because I never
knew that those things I thought that
even a prenup
I don't know I guess I'm not really good
at preparing for the worst I just didn't
even know that here's the deal I I I I
think it's one thing to batten down the
hatches if you will an old phrase that
when a storm is coming let's let's kind
of protect the windows
but you don't know that there's a storm
coming
that's a good point it's it's like you
know because you try and time everything
perfect and you worst case scenario
isn't the way you should live your
entire life Adam Adam how old are you
30. Adam I am 48 and next May or this
coming May Stacey and I will celebrate
25 years of marriage
now I'm not a marriage expert
congratulations thank you I don't say
that to get Applause I appreciate the
lobby folks saying that but I tell you
this here's what I've learned in 25
years of marriage
you can't plan for much at all other
than your emergency fund right because
life is going to happen it's gonna rain
that's why we preach the emergency fund
I would tell you this if you can afford
the house the way that we teach it to do
it and you get the house and then bring
her in once you get married and it's our
house and then if the worst happens you
still made a good financial decision and
you're still better off George I'm I'm
with you on that and when that time
comes there's a lot of state laws
there's a lot of things that you need to
take into account if it did go south and
so you can do some research do your
homework but don't let that delay you
from getting married and making it weak
that's what marriage is if you don't
want that don't sign up for marriage
it's going to end in a pain for both
parties here